so
so you like my shirt hey marilyn manson
yeah you got to be careful with your
where you wear a shirt like that right
now because it's been
canceled i believe yeah he's been
canceled officially cancelled
yeah and you're a big fan i've always
been a big fan of marilyn manson yes
since i was a little kid
the first thing i ever saw was when he
did uh like the mtv music awards or
whatever
i think i was maybe 10 years old
something something
something like that really young i was
super intrigued and followed his music
ever since yeah well
i mentioned he may have been a piece of
[ __ ] person behind doors but uh
my opinion on it my uh my you know far
away
twenty thousand foot opinion on it is
that uh if you're getting into a
relationship
uh a romantic relationship with that guy
you kind of have to have an idea what to
expect
it's not going to be normal yeah yeah
yeah
well unfortunately i think the visit was
kind of what i mentioned earlier that he
invited me up to his house and
uh i think it was last february did he
really the last
i can't even remember now um
it was well before the scandal after
your book came out
he had the book and he started reaching
out to my agent
to see if i would meet with them and he
was so cryptic in emails
that my agent didn't think it was really
him and he
told his secretary to get rid of him and
she was a fan
so she said if i get on the phone with
him i'll know whether it's him or not
and she got on the phone with him and
she said it's him and he just said i
would love to have him come to my house
i have something to show him that i
don't think he knows about
or that he's ever seen before and it
terrifies me to even possess it
so she said he said you could call him
so he and i got on the phone
he didn't think it was safe to tell me
what he had on the phone he wanted me to
come see or hear it he was being very
vague
and the fact is he didn't need anything
i mean i love going into
unusual situations and i thought
i wasn't a huge fan you know i actually
became a little bit of one when i did
some homework
but my collaborator is a musician he's
an ex-drummer and he loved him
and he had just finished and published a
book on prince where he was working with
prince
on his memoir and then prince died it's
actually how i got him as my
collaborator because when prince died
their project
came to a screeching halt and then he
had to wait a year or two
to figure out whether or not that he had
enough material to finish the book
without prince
but i told dan my collaborator i said
how would you like to go with me to
marilyn manson's i don't know if i want
to go up there alone
and because are you kidding me so he got
on the plane just to
just go up there so we went to the
castle in the hills
and uh he uh
[Music]
i don't know if he's ever gonna listen
to this uh no he won't
i've been trying to get him on this for
years yeah he'll never do it yeah
number one i i did love the guy but he
didn't have anything
what he had was an audio tape that he
thought he had found in the house
he lived at the tate house where the
murders happened he and trent rezner
moved into the oh they recorded an album
there right yeah well they were living
there and recording an album right
and while they were there he found stuff
that had been like
left behind by the previous owner and
tenants
and uh one of them was an audio tape of
roman polanski's police interrogation
and i had it already you know and it's
and you can get it
i had it actually 20 years before when
nobody had it
but in the last five or six years it
somehow got out and
their bootlegs and you can buy it online
right so it was difficult because
maryland was you know already partying
we didn't even
he said don't come before 11 o'clock at
night uh so he got up till
11 and it was actually a historic night
if you're a fan
because it was the first time he and his
guitarist who we threw out of the band a
number of years before twiggy
twiggy were together and they they had
reconciled recently yeah but they hadn't
met yet
so he invited twiggy over to um
hang out with me and dan and him and
talk about manson
and twig i guess had been through rehab
and everything they were both really
sweet guys
but twiggy was sober and maryland has
this amazing
screening room that feels more like a
harem
unsurprisingly there's no furniture you
just sit on pillows and it's
pitch black and there's just you what
would have been a huge beautiful
window with a view of the valley because
he's high up in the hills
but it's all blacked up with bricks
because i think all the windows in this
house are like that i'm not 100
sure so um we just
spent like three hours talking about the
book and he was trying to find the point
and the tapes that he said well even if
i had him you probably don't have this
and i'm pretty sure i do well and
then i thought well i'm just going to
humor him i didn't mind we were still
having fun
and but thank god for twiggy because
maryland didn't have to operate any of
the technical stuff
so twiggy was going through everything
and
were they this little like cassette
tapes or yeah they were cassette tapes
and
uh we finally when we were done
listening to them at about three or four
in the morning
let's just say there was a lot of
substances offered to us
and dan and i were on an adventure so we
accepted them twiggy stayed away from
everything right
and i think he left at about three in
the morning
and then the even better stuff came out
because he didn't want to have
the time twiggy twiggy yeah and then at
about seven in the morning
i said to dan i go because dan's 20
years younger than me i said dan
if i do any more of this stuff i'm gonna
have a massive heart attack or a stroke
i go i can't die at marilyn manson's
house he's got enough problems you know
oh my god so we literally left i think
it's 7 or 7 30 in the morning
and it was fun i mean the one thing i
can tell you about him since you are a
fan
is he's one of the smartest guys
and funniest i mean he could be a
stand-up comic
the problem was he was so kind of let's
say
feeling good that he slurs a lot and he
and he also talks under his breath and
he doesn't he's not sure he's not
performative
he'll just say these off-the-wall
remarks that almost make you piss in
your pants
and i miss so much cause he was slurring
a lot
and i thought this guy could have a
whole like 10 other career i know he
acts now
but you know he's a really intelligent
guy and you know he was having problems
with his fiance then
it was um the night before the oscars
and
they had had a huge fight because they
disagreed on what he was going to wear
to the oscar party they weren't going to
the oscars but they were going to the
big vanity fair party
and he helped dan and i helped him
decide what to wear
oh really yeah and he had already uh po
they had
been supposed to get married two or
three times already and they kept
fighting him
and cancelling it she was somewhere in
the house we never met her
who which one which which women was it
which she's going to say
she's his latest she's a filmmaker
i can't remember her name she's
beautiful i mean he and i dan and i when
we looked
her up the next day she's a beautiful
woman i don't know if she's
still with him or if she's made any of
these allegations
but he went through all his old
ex-girlfriends with us and told us
stories and
really he should have made a sign an nda
but he can trust us you know
right yeah he um did you drink any
absinthe
uh he had it yeah i not he brought out
tequila
and when dan looked at the tequila i
don't know my tequila he said this is
like a 300
bottle of tequila
and of course we're sitting on the floor
because there's no furniture and
you get kind of uncomfortable and after
you drink a lot of tequila and do a lot
of other stuff
you're not as mobile and at one point he
had brought out a second bottle of it
and i knocked it over right after we
opened it and he has a shag rug
like oh marilyn i'm so sorry i spilled a
bottle he goes oh man i got cases of
them in the basement don't worry about
it
so um oh my [ __ ] god
what a story yeah yeah you know it was
an open book we were talking about
the rumors about you know the rib being
cut out
oh yeah what did he say about that he
said it wasn't true he had a scar there
for something i can't remember half of
what happened that night luckily dan
took
notes the next day so i call up dan to
refresh
i should have done that i didn't know
you were a fan that's one of the most
classic uh rules about him is removing
the rib to set his own dick
yeah yeah yeah and he had a bunch of
funny
witty answers when people would ask him
that yeah in articles yeah
yeah but yeah he's a [ __ ] he's
incredibly intelligent
and witty yeah like on the spot being
able to just
just destroy people yeah and he had just
finished
his record which had a song or maybe it
was a title
had chaos in the in the uh in the title
oh yeah we are chaos
yeah you know my book's called chaos and
he's like
don't you try to uh sue me for
plagiarism i didn't steal it from you
it's a common word i don't don't worry
about don't worry about it but when
you're performing it you know hold the
book up or something
for your millions of fans but i guess
he's not going to tour now
yeah i don't know if he's doing anything
i don't think he's been in the public at
all since
since uh evan rachel wood came out and
said all that stuff about him
and then a couple other piled on i think
yeah yeah but i think
uh one one of his ex-wives
actually said that yeah like he does do
a lot of dark demented [ __ ]
but he never did anything that that that
was dita
right she's like you know he would never
do anything as far as like rape somebody
you're like i think he should have
stayed with her because she wasn't one
he had the nicest things
to say about when we were talking um
yeah it was uh it was a trip
and then he he texted us i knew he
wasn't going to bed
and he had mentioned at some point that
he never gets up before five in the
afternoon
and uh he did text me at like 5 30 or 6
saying he just wanted to make sure we
got home okay and we were fine i'm like
wow i said i couldn't do that a second
night in a row but
whenever you do it after i've had a few
days rest and relaxation just let me
know i'll come back
and then a couple months later he just
he texted me easter sunday morning so i
know he hadn't gone to bed yet
at like seven in the morning and just
said happy easter tom
and you know and i have marilyn manson
you know
into my phone so marilyn manson happy
easter wow
yeah oh man man it's it's kind of just
so bittersweet just
his story his life's like you can't be
that age and sustain that lifestyle
yeah yeah i don't know how so uh yeah it
was uh
he played us some new music that hadn't
been released uh so he had a
music video that hadn't been released
and
uh dan got to talk to him about music
which made him
you know so happy yeah but i'm older
school i'm like before maryland my music
was patty smith
right right the ramones and stuff like
that yeah well his obsession was with
you know those those days with the you
know the just the american obsession
with and the combination of someone like
charles manson and his story
being a serial killer he was just as
equally
you know such a part of american culture
that as marilyn monroe was
and that mixed with like the kennedy the
kennedy assassination and
all the obsession around that and just
it's just it's just fascinating how
obsessed people are with
true crime and these kind of cultural
iconic american stories